[Music]
in chef's machine news
Davidson David then you caught his
attention you're not gonna like this
what is it he's gonna love it because
it's gonna take your job yeah your job
why submitted by drive fast eat ass mmm
that's my life that's like a redneck
license plate over a bumper sticker yeah
man sick of his wife's complaining has
invented a smart robot chef yeah I feel
like a man Sigma's wife complaining
starts a lot of great invention without
the dudes cooking yes I knew new [ __ ]
yeah well this isn't China well men are
the greatest chefs in the world they are
they are absolutely yeah Chinese man
there you go Chinese man yeah so this
man he has spent the last eight years
creating this smart robot cooker now she
wants to complain like you think as soon
as he turned it on he's like well we
gonna [ __ ] about now huh oh this thing
yep oh is it China bong bong bong that's
going to be a t-shirt for sure but
that's what they sound like
yep they sound like change owners they
might not be I'm offended for them what
the [ __ ] us money you know what that
like grace when you know why
participation races China Asian [ __ ]
there's a guy at the gym that was making
some [ __ ] races as Asian jokes
however that dude trained Muay Thai in
Thailand for like five years so I can't
say it comes from a real place he's just
some man racing stuff but it was like it
was true but you would only hear that
from Asian person but I was like how's
it know all of our secrets too in some
way I like it when people know our
inside joke yeah they know the real like
they know you know that that feels like
that [ __ ] you're one of us yeah you get
it you get it that's cool John kind of
all under there no that was just
ridiculous is it's absurd it's the
stupidest [ __ ] of all time it's know
it's funny because I know Steve and then
so hearing that it's different it's
really different from like if I didn't
know him exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because I'm making fun of those
guys who do that exactly that's that's
the thing yeah yeah yeah I said that we
have to explain that to you [ __ ] see I
want to smoke out of a China bong yeah
so it'd be really cheap and Shatter soon
so yeah and the waiters when they come
with the thumb and the ball you [ __ ]
light it up does that happen yes yes
they'll literally put their [ __ ]
thumb in the soup and they'll tell you
it's really hot be careful with the bowl
[ __ ] or they'll slide it to you they'll
slide your [ __ ] [ __ ] I bet you'll
have your bowl of seats a bar you have
your bowl of soup right and it'll slide
a [ __ ] ice water cup and the ice one
will go into your soup and they do this
they do this like anything else and they
walk away
you'll come into the restaurant sit down
they go what do you want to order it's
like how the [ __ ] would I go 400 options
oh wow welcome to the 600 we won't have
to worry about that if we all got this
robot cooker here yeah what does it look
like so this dude is a CEO of a catering
company that's based in Shanghai I don't
like this robot it's [ __ ] pissing me
off man it doesn't even look like it's
there's no humanoid quality no I'm yeah
I want it to look like r2d2 or see yeah
give him eyes I need to know where he
stands like a sex robot like a sexual
about that cook what is that shoot
that's where the food
I'm acting like one that just looks like
a [ __ ] trash chute that just yeah
raps out [ __ ] yeah it needs it needs the
human quality what is it a stir-fry my
future guys you know what it reminds me
of you know that [ __ ] soda machine
that coca-cola machine with the 20
[ __ ] different brands and flavours
that one's sick dude I won't know that
I've made it until I have that amount
who cannot have that in your house
though why her DJ you need yes so you
you can only have only certain
businesses can have that machine you
can't like some random [ __ ] can't have
it's like it's like certain restaurants
you have to apply for it or some [ __ ]
like that you can't just have it why are
you so any hey so the reason why I
looked it up is because I was wondering
if we begin for the office saying so
David yeah cuz you can get so you can't
get that machine it's not that he's
behind Express five guys uh where else I
know where one is it's at this peri-peri
chicken place if I'm somebody cool them
oh maybe there's some little Mars I
can't get it maybe if you're right
nobody ever be on yeah cuz I was
thinking like well I wanted it that for
the office instead of that [ __ ]
little thing that we always at the flip
out drinks but we can't what can you get
you get like a Shasta machine RC Cola
you know what you can't get this robot
cooker oh wait let me see this [ __ ] so
this thing it it's available for rent to
rent and so they're saying for a
thousand five hundred eighty eight US
dollars that's the bit that's the
deposit require equal to rent it
plus one yuan or 16 US cents for every
dish that it cooks that's it and it's
yeah it's only 16 cents and a lot of
people are trying to sell it they were
like I was actually really good and then
the wife has not complained about the
cooking ever oh I thought I was gonna be
like well she doesn't think it's good
for seven years
tofu is that what kind of roots but I
couldn't find that answer
it's Chinese personally I'm starving out
of my [ __ ] mind and I just want food
now that would be great yeah it's
probably I hope the alternative than
just getting like instant noodles or
something its own cleaning system Oh
think about it a machine that exists
sole purpose exists to make good food
like not even chefs are out there
feeling that way like half of the
restaurants you go to they don't give a
flying [ __ ] yeah but she don't have an
opinion yeah
cuz she's one job it's like literally
put here to do a job and it does it like
I trust a machine mark this is how we're
gonna lose the [ __ ] planet to robot
no this is how we're gonna save the
planet geo we're gonna make the planet
better what yeah I start thinking for
itself and we're [ __ ] no if it starts
to think for itself
well unplug the [ __ ] there's gonna be
so many climb on its back and we'll
start pulling wires out like they do in
the movies you know what's gonna happen
though there's gonna be so many Chinese
chefs out of the job so all the alleys
of China is just gonna have non stop
smoking guys with three sick like three
[ __ ] teeth smoking a cigarette like
Crouching in an alley because they don't
have it you know or you are the bomb a
street food of all time that has ever
existed so yeah [ __ ] the [ __ ] I'm with
you Joe that's really sad with all the
vending machines for the drinks but
instead it'll be B and you can but most
likely I tied for sixty-seven cents all
everyone's out of a job
holy [ __ ] do they tell you how it works
because I'm like so what do you do you
just leave like the bell peppers and the
[ __ ] chicken and you just leave it in
there they never do cuz they don't want
you to know how to do it they never tell
you I always took that say that it takes
a cooker three to four minutes to cook a
dish that's it fast and that it has its
automatic cleaning system but yeah it
doesn't really your [ __ ] admit it that's
nothing sighs that's ridiculous
there is this one on this in this
article they're saying that a week raivo
user commented this the most difficult
part of cooking is not stir-frying
dishes but preparing raw materials it
seems that the cooker hasn't solved the
problem of cleaning and cutting whole
[ __ ] you they just invented a [ __ ]
machine what did you do yeah what did
you do pal yeah exactly you binge watch
Netflix last night fell asleep and then
today you got the longest cross that is
the longest process it is why the wife
[ __ ] on his [ __ ] career me why she
don't his problem oh if that was
negative I all I heard was that that's
the next step he needs to do in salt I
heard a real winery I did I did too I
don't know because that the best thing I
was wondering is like where do you put
the food you know what I feel like you
might already be a preset menu so it's
like these are the three dishes that you
have and then just these are the
ingredients yeah I don't scream here's
what I would do is like I would have a
chicken compartment right I would have
like a beef compartment I would just
throw that [ __ ] and in here's where the
salt is whatever I didn't what's it
another thing is this guys renting it
therefore he's preparing all the raw
materials yeah here's the sea alligator
soft so you keep like already dealing
with a lot of food yeah
also if you have this in your house it's
like the Sparkletts water people you
know how they bring that over they
refill it they should have people that
come over fill up your machine and clean
it up yeah but they can't pick whatever
menu you want that weaker cuz the [ __ ]
is gonna be cleaning out that's why this
is already flawed right because they're
always you're always gonna have a
problem cleaning it out didn't he say
that there's probably the feeding tray
or some [ __ ]
no no no the the comment was saying that
they haven't solved the problem of its
prepping so like you have to dice the
chicken you have to do all that system
right see until we're able cuz
everything's made out of atoms and
molecules in certain way like Star Trek
and Star Trek once they figure out how
to arrange whatever the [ __ ] it is in
the perfect molecule like formative
machine it's all about doing it I've
seen the fly I'm not doing that
why cuz I've seen the flop what are you
good at the most delicious food
delivered right to you and you're scary
what happens in the flight so there's
this guy that's been in the
teleportation machine and he breaks up
the molecules and atoms and all that
[ __ ] and then fly man yeah and then he
had Jeff Goldblum Jeff Goldblum that
[ __ ] creep me up ah so then he gets
in the machine to keep testing it out
and then he doesn't realize that there's
a fly in there with him and then when he
transfers over to the other side of the
teleportation machine then he's yeah his
DNA got mixed with the flies and he
slowly starts transforming itself fun he
starts pulling off his skin and there's
like all this fur and then he's still
kind of hot Jeff Goldblum hot you know
trying to fly he was hot hot [ __ ] Jeff
Goldblum like a sex symbol attorny sir
sure absolutely
[Music]
[Music]